good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all of the world's major
problems so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn how to have
fun over the you huge Ackman when the
things most matter you so desperately
don't want to destroy it for being
scared that you can really destroy it
sure when I hosted the Oscars I was I
was like wow man this is a billion
people and I just thought okay whatever
you do just remember you're a kid from
moronga in Sydney you're hosting the
Oscars have some fun you know and
luckily for me those turning points I've
somehow always stuck to that idea of
just having fun if you're not having fun
you're never going to shine if you're
not having fun and you're constantly
stressed and you're constantly worried
and you're constantly freaking out then
you're not going to have fun you're
customers aren't going to have fun your
suppliers are going to have fun and
you're never going to be able to build a
business that you want to build I think
you have to attack it from both sides
where you want to build a better future
you want to be upset about what you've
created and you want to build something
greater and at the same time have fun
and be grateful and recognize all the
amazing things that you have currently
built up it's both if all you're doing
is find a happy lalala then you never
strive to improve and if all you're
focusing on is improvement in getting
better then you're never happy do you
need to have both one of the things that
I encourage my instructors here to do at
China dance salsa is to have fun in
their class and their students will have
fun our customers will have fun if the
instructor is genuinely having fun and
that looks different for different
people one instructor might tell a lot
of silly jokes one instructor might be
goofy at the front one instructor you
know might put on a song that makes them
really happy it doesn't matter what it
is it has to be individual to each
person and I can't tell that person
here's what you need to do to have more
fun they already know
but for their class to be more fun they
have to actually be having fun in the
class and so if you take that to your
business yes you want to strive yes you
want to grow yes you want to push yes
you want the best yes you want to
improve and at the same time you want to
enjoy what you have you want to have fun
you want to be grateful and you want to
remember this moment is something
special in history sometimes it can be
hard to remember to do it but even just
a simple reminder can help if you feel
yourself getting really stressed out
freaking out not being clear
snapping at people just a reminder to
say how can I have a little more fun in
this or what am i grateful for today or
how can I make the situation better to
cool yourself down gain a little more
perspective and help you go off and
accomplish the big goals that you've set
for yourself so the question today is
I'm curious what do you do in your
business to have a little fun leave it
down in the comments below super curious
to find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to Shari but I will pronounce
that ok from HMS host calm thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word I really appreciate it and
I hope you're enjoying reading so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you
I hope you can seem to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I will see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events press oh
oh
our friend told me go
like Avengers it seemed like you were
having a great time I am NOT a great not
a huge acting challenge for you I
imagine by the bin we seem to be having
fun what fun is important this should be
a fun job it's make-believe if you and
your friends with real costumes and
better guns and [ __ ] doing the thing you
know exciting people it's that's what
that's about when you're doing something
like the Avengers you got to take it
seriously in in in terms of you believe
the space you're in you believe the
world and the convention of it that
there are people who can do greater than
normal human beings can do trust that go
with it
treat them like they're those kinds of
people and they have an element of
danger and an element of awe that comes
with all that that's the honesty of the
world but you know Nick Fury I got some
with me too so I can be you know boom I
can stand up to him and say what I need
to say and sometimes like in the
Avengers I need to manipulate these
people I got to where I am because I'm
Nick Fury I can just nobody knows how
old I am or why I'm still still alive or
why I'm now black when I used to be
white you know so I guess let me do know
you could you accept that and you go
with it and you treat it like it's some
my honest and you treat it like it's
something real so when people come and
see it they don't see you going you know
I'm in it I'm in it is some dangerous
happening and you can help us fix that
so let's go get them looks like you and
your friends doing that when you were
kids let's go get him go get him huh you
know and then you shoot make it say you
missed cuz the chance blow up and all
that kind of great so even with these
movies under your belt you came out to
LA and you were still thinking it was
going to be for PA work still thought
you'd be able oh I mean I didn't know I
still I was believing more I mean I sure
did like but I was doing and I had
people and I couldn't you know honestly
at that time
there's $320 you know I was like reduce
illegal today was so much fun and
show everyone and I kept fitted like
that and then I have some Oklahoma bar
hey man you're good at this I was like
well thanks because it should fun um so
I really didn't I really didn't know
I guess secretly if I look back I and I
looked at my Diaries ever there was
hopeful underlying but I was still like
I need to go out and get a job and I can
pursue acting on the side I'd get a good
PA job get this going telling biz behind
the camera and and let's see and then
another funny thing happened at that
first audition when I got out here was
forecasting arrangement can hmm now I'm
talking about is for for clinical boys
inside and I went in red and he goes
spec setting he did really good I'll
have him for a callback
sometimes I went off from there I could
call again for baseball Kim angels in
the outfield I walk in the door this is
decision there's a bunch of funny
peculiar how the hell I got to be
standing here today I walk in the door
was backlit iron erotic spit out had a
American cap on because I'm Warner
Brothers loud I open up the doors
backlit in the afternoon
producers sitting on the couch he looks
at me with a jig the almighty did
plays a boss in 12 years because she got
a job gonna send me they claim is
regular 48 5 worried about about a novel
play baseball 11 weeks and open again
I'm doing what is this business but it
happened in during that I got caught
like three four herbert ross boys on the
side you got that role and so I bet that
Coen Brothers film got pushed that P a
job that I would have taken if it was
there never happened and I haven't
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way I believe in winners and
losers and especially the freedom to
fail him who can don't have fun you're
not going to have fun every minute of
every day I don't care what job you take
you know any job you take I don't care
how well rewarded you are I don't care
anything about that
it won't happen all the time but you
better be having fun in what you do the
truth is a lot of success won't just
come from ideas and and being hardcore
and being in the weight room a lot of
your success is going to come from luck
I know that was true in my case
and I know frankly it's the case of
almost every successful entrepreneur I
met the tech business in the last thirty
four years people will make it seem like
what's the grand master plan in all
cases of an all-knowing and all-seeing
genius that a lot of luck is what really
leads to success so given that you're
going to have to have a lot of luck you
better be having a lot of fun don't take
the next job or don't do the next
startup because you should do it because
you want to because you can think of
nothing better more exciting more
energizing to get up every day and go do
than whatever it is that you selected be
patient and be urgent when it's our be
patient when you get the first signs
that it's not fun because time must be
measured constantly be improving
yourself because only by improving
yourself will you maybe find that next
idea I'm sure there are many people in
this audience who'd like to do a
start-up and yet the first law of doing
a start-up
is you got to have an idea but if you're
having fun if you're building
capabilities if you're treasure
in your time if you're building your
muscle and being hardcore the good ideas
will come to you